there are plenty of women out there who
are virgins who have never had
experience or anything like that that
are running around saying men are trash
maybe they might have a bad relationship
with their dads or whatever or maybe
they've just heard from their aunties or
their sisters oh this is my relationship
with these terrible men out here men are
trash they've become an indoctrinated to
it
but if they don't have a healthy
relationship with men then how do you
expect them to kind of have any other
view i don't know any virgins that have
that view that men are trash every girl
that i know that that says that stuff
is just a girl that has been pretty much
been ran through yeah like honestly like
you know it's a girl that's been ran
through or she's she's shooting too high
and none of her friends are nice enough
to say hey
yeah that guy will see you like once a
week and screw you but he's never going
to be seen in public with you yeah is
there something about you know that
female dynamic where those friends won't
is there a reason why those friends
won't tell we're more agreeable than men
i'll
yeah i would tell them obviously i would
tell them too but i don't we don't
really see it well i don't see it as
not a bad not not bad thing but like i'm
not trying to put them down yeah yeah
and make them feel
well yeah but i think there's a
difference between putting someone down
and letting them live in delusion that
is true so so if i have a friend that's
like let's let's let's say she's a five
and that's not a bad thing if you're
five that means you're average looking
most people are average looking so so if
i have a girl a friend that's a five and
she's constantly having like sleeping
with guys that are eights nines and tens
and she's constantly getting her heart
broken
like don't you think it's nicer to just
say hey maybe maybe date a little 100 a
little lower 100
yes
yes because you think and like in her
head she thinks that the guy wants her
because of like just because he's
sleeping with you and sometimes girls
don't really realize that no he just
wants to have sex with you
do you know what i mean wouldn't you
rather go for a man that you think wants
to marry you right of course
yeah i think that's an issue then that's
the thing girls want yeah in the first
place and that's probably why sometimes
screwed yes it's just like they have a
good image of the guy in the first place
and it's just like okay
he's done me wrong the first time let me
give him another chance he's down around
the second time he's just like
you're always putting hope into that guy
so now i was just like like you said
when your friends are looking at you
like okay quite see your the guy is
screwing you just like no like he's calm
like these people are collecting red
flags no honey
so that's just you settling from the
time he's screwing you and he's just
doing it over and over again you're
literally settling just for that quick
question
are you saying are you saying you're
settling for the guy just sleeping with
you yeah that's that link i feel like
that's certainly right
that is settling because that is that
all you're going to do mm-hmm
you're not going on dates you're not
meeting family you're not going out
you're not having fun but you're just
kidding me in my bedroom and you're like
they want you in the beginning
sorry they will act like they want you
in the beginning that's the thing that
sometimes sometimes girls actually don't
know
like even though you did it you don't go
on dates and all that stuff but then
they they don't realize that you're not
going on days they just like they're
just
in my experience i think guys tell you
pretty early what they want and girls
are just afraid to ask them what they're
looking for and and because they're
scared of like scaring them away
but like when you ask a guy what you're
looking for in your upfront and honest
it seems like you get the best results
because then you get guys that are
actually on your level
yeah but like i don't find that most
guys are trying to deceive you early on
like i find that most guys that like
most of my friends that have ended up in
situation ships the guy said i'm not
looking for anything serious and she
agreed to it
and then three months later when she's
in love mm-hmm she is wonderful she she
loves she'll blame the guy even though
you you agreed yeah that that's her
fault though right yes 100 is because he
clearly said i don't want anything okay
cool but some guys don't say that though
i'm sorry some guys actually act like
they're like you they take you out at
first it's true they compliment you
they're like right and then they get to
know you they get you yeah they get to
know you a little bit you remember like
you said they start screwing you from
the time they start screwing you
over because the task is done yeah
the task is missing
he got what you wanted yeah he got what
you wanted yeah but also sometimes i
think those guys maybe were interested
to start but the girl doesn't offer
anything but but sex
so she thinks she's above like cooking
for a guy cleaning for a guy she thinks
she's above
making that guy's life better and so
then of course he's just going to use
you for sex if you have nothing else to
offer but sex yeah
right yeah but obviously you're not
going to move in straight away exactly
cooking clean i mean i know you're just
using it
if you don't move in
or whatever like you know that's all
right actually oh wow i need to see that
you're here forever but i would consider
that so you need commitment before you
do all of those things is that what
you're saying sorry you need commitment
before you show i need to see that
you're actually here for a long time i'm
not
gonna be doing certain duties and you're
not here long time sorry but why would
he commit to you if he doesn't see what
he's gonna get exactly so why am i gonna
cook clean yeah all of this you're not
i'm not your mum sorry but why would you
then sleep with a man if you wouldn't
cook for him or clean for him how'd you
know i'm sleeping with him
sorry i am just assuming okay yeah yeah
yeah but you never know you never know
you never know like it just depends like
at the level would would that mean you'd
be finessing him then no one's like that
don't do that
no no because you're you're you're
answering questions with questions so
now i'll put that question to you
but that's not i don't i don't really
see that as finishing i feel like it's
just a way of like
showing okay i'm interested in you
i'm seeing this as long term
so
if you're saying this as long time it
depends on what like how long it takes
to fall for that person and how long
that connection
gets stronger if i can see that you're
being serious about me then yes okay
cool i can cook for you i can come to
your house and whatever we can but what
if what if he says i won't spend money
on you until i see you're serious about
me what if i won't spend the money on
you what if what if the guy says i won't
spend money on you until i see you're
serious about me that's fine
no but i will show you that's fine on me
i got my own money
what does it look like for a man to be
serious about you
good communication
yeah
honesty
um what else loyalty yeah loyalty
um so i'd say it's the same vice versa
yeah of course 100 100 percent i feel
like it's like a 50 50 thing like yeah i
don't see his head
in your head
aren't you shaking your head i would
hear you okay
me personally i think it's like if
you're getting to know someone like i
think it's 50 50 because
like
i don't think it's always the guy that
needs to be
doing this this this this this
to show that they're interested yes you
would like that we would like that as a
female but
like what she was saying if you he's if
he's not getting that at the same time
like what's the point how would how
would he know that i'm interested as
well
what because i'm seeing you every now
and then because you asked like
is that really gonna show you're
interested
i don't think it's 50 50. i think we all
have our roles and responsibilities 100
so then understanding that we have our
roles and responsibilities how can it
ever be 50 50. if we go on a date
i'm taking you out i should be paying
don't get me wrong wait wait don't get
me wrong under the relationship dynamics
of like
if you're in a couple together then you
can have that discussion as to whether
what works for you guys but
i don't know fair enough no no sorry
but can i just ask you this then so if
you was dating
like before a relationship you wouldn't
let your girl like the person you're
talking to
like pay for a date
if she wanted to that's different i'll
take you out i think can i can i sorry
can i add on i think like what you said
like if you take a go out you pay for
for me personally like if it was vice
versa if i if i took a guy out on a date
i would pay because i'm paying for his
time and i'm like that's what i'm asking
you know would you not let a girl do
that
but i think no i think that's different
because he asked the girl out he's the
one that's initiating
that he wants to take her do you know
what i mean like this is how it happens
i said this on the lasso or something
if a girl
was to pay for me
to go out on a date yeah i'd be
questioning why she's paying for me like
and the reason why i'd say i would go
why is she trying to secure me like as a
man i should be able to pick my woman
right
girls should not be picking their men
and if they're doing the pick me thing
and they're like trying to get a man
what's wrong with her that's what i'm
questioning like why does she want me to
get her why is she trying to secure me
but what's wrong with that what's wrong
with that maybe are you saying women
shouldn't choose their partners i'm
saying guys should choose their partners
i'm saying women should essentially
throw out the handkerchief to
let the man know that oh
i'm feeding you but men should make the
initial move to a woman well what time
or whatever what if she what if you was
actually feeding her though like if she
was if she paid for your date and like
did stuff for you then the times have
you paid for a man's date
how many times have you paid for him
i've only paid once and i
didn't go once how did it go it was a
good day it was a good day i mean did
you see that man again the [ __ ] now
[Laughter]
can i say something can i say something
before y'all attack me
that was actually my first date ever
oh so he done you died yeah
no he did he did he did i can go on
because rav yeah yeah you don't know who
he is yeah yeah yeah you don't know who
he is yeah yeah you're probably watching
this
but yeah
no i paid and he actually went calm like
it was a talk yeah it was a calm date
but like obviously stuff happened and
like he i realized that he wasn't like i
wasn't the guilt that he was into it and
that's okay but it was in order for me
to learn because i didn't know anything
about dating relationships and like
anything back then so
it was enough so then you learn you
don't pay a holiday a man no but there's
nothing wrong with that oh okay so one
thing i will say to you is yeah i know
you may not see the consequences of your
actions by paying for a date but word of
advice from me
don't pay on the first date with a man
oh i know that now i'm not i'm never
paying for the first time
i thought we were talking about paying
for dates in general is that what we
were talking about yeah that's what i
was first i i think we were just
speaking about
roles and yeah also than anything 50 50
a better example if a burglar comes into
the house
are we 50 50 defending each other
for the draft should it be 50 50 50 men
50 percent women going to work
so if there's a war and they have to
draft people yeah you should be 50 50.
nope
you're going to do one i'm not gonna i
mean it depends what i'm gonna go to the
wall it depends on what we're doing yeah
i know i'm gonna have friends fight like
fighting the combat yeah
risk my life yeah but
she's not talking about you either she's
talking about in general yeah what why
not
would you prefer if i
stayed at home and you guys went to
fight the wars for example you wouldn't
right or like in general i can't lie
when i said 50 50. i didn't mean like
every single thing yeah yeah yeah i
meant like certain things yeah yeah so
it's just like selecting the quality
yeah
i know that found a bit more
a common complaint i hear from men is
that women only fight for equality when
it doesn't benefit us but we never want
any of the drawbacks
so for example um we'll happily take the
free drinks the free dates and getting
into bars for free but if the rolls were
reversed we would throw a fit if the men
got into the bars for free and we had to
pay
that's just true that's true
it's mad but that's true
and we never hear women talk about um
like we hear about the pay gap but we
never talk about how men have the harder
jobs like plumbing electric
the building
women do those jobs too no they don't
not statistics it's like less than two
percent in those industries they don't
so but out of those women
how many of them are getting paid the
same as the men that do the exact same
thing that is true yeah how many
women get paid the same as men when you
take into account the number of hours
worked
and you take into account the industries
that they pick there's no pay gap it's
been debunked multiple times
okay
yeah i'd say nowadays it doesn't exist
because they've made the equal pay act
right which was introduced in the 70s
right
i think
i think yeah people who use that women
that use the argument nowadays they
clearly haven't done their research fair
enough i understand that
and i think we as women we do have
privilege in certain contexts and i do
think that's unfair personally i do
think that should be addressed and i
think i personally don't think about
that and i'm glad you brought that up
because i don't i don't consciously
think about that i don't get bought
drinks often a lot in clubs but if i do
i will take it and i'm not going to go
around buying a guy a drink personally i
wouldn't i'd be scared
thank you i wouldn't but i have to see
you by me so you're all spiky
[Music]
looking at you all the time yeah i'm
like
um no i was just saying i i see
your point there and that yeah in
certain context we do have privilege and
i get your point about the pay gap i
don't think that is really an issue
anymore but i do think in certain
industries like the plumbing and the
whatever else you said
um yeah there are a lot less
statistically women that are doing that
but i also think that
so we've been socialized to not want to
do them jobs and i still do think that
is an issue and i think that we should
have more
i know there are opportunities out there
but i just feel like they're not
advertised enough for us and they should
be pushed in things like secondary
schools and primary schools and they're
not